haití conmemoró el primer aniversario
del asesinato del presidente joven el
mois su esposa martín moix y sus hijos
acudieron al panteón nacional donde se
levantó un mausoleo en memoria del
mandatario pero se retiraron antes de
que empezara la ceremonia formal de
homenaje que contó con la presencia de
diplomáticos funcionarios y el primer
ministro hay el ángel
[Música]
mucho mejor que hoy
y un año después de este asesinato
seguimos en duelo el pueblo haitiano
está en duelo y eso nos obliga a
cuestionar como individuos que tienen un
nombre que tienen un mínimo de humanidad
han podido cometer fríamente semejante
atrocidad
[Música]
y la policía haitiana ha detenido a más
de 40 personas pero aún no ha acusado a
nadie del magnicidio el primer ministro
hay el ángel se ha enfrentado a
acusaciones de estar involucrado en el
complot incluso por parte de la viuda de
maurice que resultó herida durante el
ataque pero angie y niega estar
implicado en el homicidio e insiste en
que su gobierno está comprometido a
llevar a los asesinos ante la justicia
[Música]
reveló aquí ante la nación mi
determinación de incentivar sin
cansancio el seguimiento de la
investigación hasta el final la justicia
haitiana puede contar con el apoyo
indefectible del gobierno
[Música]
el caso ha sido asignado a un quinto
juez después de que los cuatro
anteriores renunciaron ante las quejas
de intimidación y amenazas a su
seguridad personal
entre tanto partidarios de moix han
convocado una manifestación este jueves
para pedir justicia por su asesinato